KAREN BASS, RUNNING TO REPLACE
ERIC GARCETI.
>> Carley: FINAL CAMPAIGN
STRETCH.
>> I LOVE THE SIGNS WHEN I CAME
IN, SOCIALISM.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
WHAT IDIOTS.
>> THERE ARE 330 MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE COUNTRY, MAYBE 80 TO 90
MILLION ARE NOT VERY BRIGHT.
>> Todd: JOE CONCHA JOINS THE
SHOW, IS THAT NAME-CALLING AND
INSULT SIGN OF DESPERATION ON
THE LEFT?
>> Joe: IT IS A SIGN OF STUPID
ITS, TODD, TO INSULT VOTERS YOU
ARE TRYING TO COURT A FEW DAYS
BEFORE THE MIDTERM, HOW DOES
THAT WIN YOU ANYTHING, EXCEPT A
CHEAP APPLAUSE LINE.
MICHAEL MOORE IS SAYING
DEMOCRATS WILL PICK UP SEATS IN
THE HOUSE AND SENATE AND THAT
COULD HAPPEN PERHAPS IF YOU
BELIEVE IN 1% OF A CHANCE
HAPPENING AS WE ARE TALKING AS
FAR AS THE HOUSE IS CONCERNED.
I DON'T GET THIS STRATEGY AT THE
END, IT IS ALL DEFLECTION.
THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT INFLATION,
WAGES, NOT KEEPING UP, CAN'T
TALK ABOUT CRIME, GAS PRICES,
BORDERS, EDUCATION, GOES BACK TO
FOURTH GRADE, NAME CALLING.
>> Carley: CAN'T TALK ABOUT
THOSE THINGS, THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT THREATS TO DEMOCRACY AND
ABORTION AND OP-EDS BEING
WRITTEN SAYING DEMOCRATS MISSED
THE MARK ON GETTING THE PULSE OF
THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU THINK THERE WAS A MAJOR
MISTAKE MADE THERE AND MAYBE IT
IS DIFFICULT FOR DEMOCRATS TO
ADDRESS THE REAL ISSUES BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE PARTY IN POWER,
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE HEADLINES
WILL BE COME NOVEMBER 9 IF THERE
IS A RED SWEEP?
>> Joe: TONE DEAF.
RIGHT?
THAT IS THE ONLY TWO WORDS YOU
WILL SEE IN THE HEADLINES, AS
FAR AS STRATEGY, TO SAY
INFLATION DOESN'T EXIST.
OR THE PRESIDENT TRIED TO CLAIM
WE WERE AT ZERO INFLATION, YOU
SEE CANDIDATES LIKE KATHY HOCHUL
IN NEW YORK CLAIMING CRIME THAT
IS UP BY EVERY STATISTIC, NOT
EVEN AN OPINION, THIS IS HOW I
FEEL, WHEN YOU LOOK AT STATS,
CRIME IS WAY UP AS FAR AS
MURDERS, HOMICIDES, VIOLENT
CRIME.
IT IS A MEDIA CREATION, WHEN
THEY SAY THE BORDER IS CLOSED
AND YOU SEE THE REPORTS FROM
BILL AND THEY SAY THEY ARE NOT
WOKE CURRICULUMS BEING PUSHED.
THEY ARE AND IT IS ON PAPER.
THAT SAYS WE WILL NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM, WE DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE
THE PROBLEM EXISTS THAT IS WHERE
HEADLINES WILL BE, DEMOCRATS
TRIED TO CLAIM I THINK THISES
DIDN'T EXIST DID EXIST AND
REALIZE THIS IS WHAT VOTERS ARE
THINKING THAT LIFE IS NOT AN
MSNBC PROGRAM, THEN THEY WAY TOO
LATE AS FAR AS THAT IS
CONCERNED.
>> Todd: MSNBC PROGRAM, NBC
PROGRAM, "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE"
HAVING FUN AT THE PRESIDENT'S
EXPENSE THIS WEEKEND, WATCH.
>> MIDTERM ELECTION WILL
DETERMINE FATE OF DEMOCRACY AND
LET'S SAY BIG YOOIKS, WHAT IS
GOING ON?
THE DEMOCRAT MESSAGE IS NOT
GETTING THROUGH, I'M TALKING TO
PEOPLE THAT DON'T EXIST, THAT
DOESN'T HELP MUCH.
I'M TRYING, I PROMISE, I AM
TEMPTING FATE.
>> Todd: HOW MUCH STOCK DO YOU
PUT IN THAT IN TERMS OF
DEMOCRATS ENTHUSIASM TO GET OUT
THEIR VOTE THIS ELECTION?
I LOOK AND THINK, BOY, THEY HAVE
NO FIRE TO GET OUT, THEY KNOW
THEIR GOOSE IS COOKED, WHAT SAY
YOU?
>> Joe: 1ST OF ALL, I CAN'T GET
OVER HOW HORRIBLE THAT
IMMITATION OF BIDEN IS, DANA
CARVY NAILED IT AND DARRELL
HANNAH AND WILL FARRELL WITH
GEORGE W. BUSH.
TO YOUR POINT, TODD, ENTHUSIASM
IS DAMPENED, THEY SEE THE
WRITING ON THE WALL AND KNOW THE
BIDEN PRESIDENCY, EVEN WHEN HE
HAD THE HOUSE AND SENATE DIDN'T
GET TOO MUCH DONE.
THEY KNOW THIS IS DONE AND
TALKING ABOUT THE 2024 CAMPAIGN,
PARTICULARLY IF DONALD TRUMP
ANNOUNCES HE IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AND NOVEMBER 14th.
>> Carley: "SNL" DIDN'T MAKE FUN
OF THE DEMOCRATI